- So we were talking about TikTok earlier,
are you in love with TikTok?
- I wasn't, until COVID
happened and I am now.
I think, the craziness of
all things in motherhood,
I did this one where--
(Kelly laughing)
- This is my favorite.
- Oh yes.
- [Children] Mom!
(Kelly laughing)
- So my favorite thing to
do in the whole wide world,
is clean the kitchen, so
that then I can cook again.
So then I can cook again,
then I can clean again,
then I can cook again.
- Oh my gosh I feel you.
(Derek laughing)
- No but literally,
I think I literally was
hiding in my closet.
This sounds terrible, but
like I hide from my children.
(Derek laughs)
- [Kelly] Every parent does it,
and if you say you don't you're a liar.
- I hide from my children.
- [Kelly] You need a minute.
- And I drink wine in the closet,
(Kelly laughs)
I get ready in the closet.
Even today my three-year-old
Gray, he was like,
"Are you going to the closet?"
But literally he's like the type of child
who's like, "Mom,
"mom are you watching?
"Mom."
And I finally look over
and he (laughs) on my life,
he takes a sip of water.
I'm like, that's what
you wanted me to watch?
- Oh my gosh it's like
Stewie from Family Guy.
Mom, mommy.
- Mama.
- Yeah, that's a real episode,
that's not just funny.
- And so I think with TikTok,
and I know Derek, I
was just like screw it,
I'm just gonna show you the craziness
of the changing of the
diapers and the butt wiping
and the bottles and the...
And I have to say it's been
quite freeing in a weird way.
I would always say to people,
I don't really look like that,
my family doesn't really look like...
It's the best version of
'97 pictures taken after.
(Kelly laughing)
You know what I mean?
'Cause Instagram isn't real.
It's not, it's just the
best version of yourself,
or your family
or whatever it is.
- It's like the filtered
version of us, yeah.
- And so I think with TikTok
I think people,
not that they didn't think
I did all those things,
I feel I'm a good mom, but
I cook like 300 meals a day.
- Oh my gosh,
where would you hide in
the house if you had to?
- Me?
- [Kelly] yes.
- It's the bathroom.
You ever seen that Paul Rudd...
- I literally was just
gonna say when he's playing
his game on the toilet,
I'm like I've totally...
- That's me.
It might be TMI but that's definitely me.
- No, This Is 40.
That's that movie, This Is 40.
- Yeah, I'm not quite there yet
but that's my habit.
- Dude, I'm with you.
I was literally gonna
say mine is the bathroom,
'cause it's the one thing
I can feel not mean about,
or guilty like, mommy needs a minute.
I just need to go to the bathroom
and then a lot of times I'm
not going to the bathroom.
(Derek laughs)
I'm just sitting in there.
- If I post something on Instagram
or something like that,
and it could be something
I learn or read about,
it's something really serious.
It's all created within
the bathroom (laughs),
it all happens there.
It's the office yeah.
(Kelly and Derek laughing)
- You guys, I run fake errands.
I will go and pretend that
I have to go somewhere
and I'll sit in my car.
I did a TikTok on it.
(Kelly laughing)
I literally will go
and I'm like, "Bye."
And they're like,
"Bye, I'll miss you, I'm
going to the grocery,
"I've got tons to do."
I won't go anywhere ill just sit there.
(Derek laughs)
- [Kelly] You just need a minute,
and then you're a better parent.
- I'm a better parent.
- You're better parent
when you have some me time.
- Wait, can we just discuss one thing?
- Yeah.
- I was backstage, were
you really in Harry Potter?
- [Derek] yeah.
- [Kelly] You Love Harry Potter?
- Stop it.
- I guess,
I'm kind of big deal.
(audience laughing)
- We love you.
(Derek mumbles)
- Since COVID, we
crushed all the episodes.
I mean every Sunday, crushed it.
We built, I mean it's basically an owe to
Harry Potter, Lego Land, Auto House.
My husband--
- I love Legos.
- Literally Hogwarts, 72 vodka sodas later
and 61 juice boxes.
He completed the castle.
- [Derek] What?
- Oh there (laughs),
the castle.
Look at that.
- You have no idea.
- [Kelly] I do actually.
- I want to come build that with you.
That's so fun.
- My house, my whole breakfast
area, and the kids play,
I have a whole like kids arts,
it looks like a little school
section, Legos are everywhere.
- You love Legos.
- It's so therapeutic.
You should join in.
- I do.
I'm not as fast.
He'll do like, "You're
not as fast as daddy."
- Oh see, I'm like that with my kids.
(laughs)I'm so bad.
I'm like, "Oh, did you
want mommy to do it?
"Oh, I'm fine doing it."
and then cut to it, they're coloring
and I'm like putting together
this thing on my own.
(laughing)
- I swear that is my husband.
He will be--
- [Kelly] It's so good.
- He might have something
to drink next to him,
and the kids would be
like watching Garfield.
- I don't even have anything
to drink or eat next to me
if it gets in my way, I'm
like so in (laughter).
I did the whole Friends set,
I haven't done Harry Potter
but yes, you were cooler than us
'cause you were in Harry Potter.
- I mean honestly, I was a
little damn like ten years late
to Harry Potter by the way.
- Oh, I read all the books before--
- I'm in the middle of
it right now actually,
- [Blonde lady] oh, it's so good.
- I'm on definitely
Harry's part two right now.
So it shall continue tonight, marathon.
- Wow, it's gonna be a good night.